aux mêmes qui ont mis en données brutes
à la commémorative et jouer les contres
à fond du moto club anglais you cette
fois entendu au début mais aussi à la
fin de ce nouveau clip de leur escale h
suivant quelques secondes est celle de
l'officier de la police nationale
ribeiro utilisation sans son
consentement
une vidéo du nom de madame installé sur
youtube double 14 points produits
le fonctionnaire de police majeure de
son grade affecté à la bac est aussi
secrétaire départemental adjoint du
syndicat alliance police dans ce sonore
partagé dans un groupe privé il déploré
les conditions dans lesquelles rang
rochis comment cette vidéo avait été
réalisé à fort de france
aujourd'hui son avocat estime qu'il ya
eu utilisation abusive de la voix de son
client il a assigné en référé
kalash de volcans de connaissance il
s'agit de notes est manifestée au doigt
à l'image de monsieur ben oui liberté en
violation de l'article 9 du code civil
qui effectivement dit que pertes
on a doit respect de sa vie privée toute
violation de ces dispositions antam des
dommages intérêts aujourd'hui la vie de
monsieur vous oubliez telle est en
danger du fait de monsieur kalach qui a
effectivement diffuser ce clip avec la
voix de monsieur bâté sur son
consentement
un clip largement commentée il a déjà
fait 2 millions de vues sur youtube son
avocat parle de préjudice moral
important
il ya certainement préjudice moral et
qui est très important que on n'est pas
encore en mesure de chiffrer mais en
tout cas ce préjudice il est
incommensurable incommensurable des
locaux monsieur berthet voix contre lui
dans des menaces des menaces de mort il
ya même des vidéos ou des clips ou des
photos qui ont circulé avec sa tête est
mise à prix
l'audience de référé devrait se tenir en
principe cette semaine une action au
civil et au pénal plainte pour menaces
de mort à l'encontre d'un dépositaire de
l'autorité publique est enregistrée par
le parquet de fort de france